tributes to the man who twice ran Chile
former president Sebastian Pinera died
in a helicopter crash on Tuesday he was
74 I ordered former president Sebastian
Pinera to receive the honors of a state
funeral and declared three days of
mourning to honor the memory of the man
who was elected two times as President
of Chile some Chileans remember him as a
leader who improved their
[Music]
economy he was a great president someone
who always fought for his country and
never had a know he stood out in every
way even worldwide due to the rescue of
the trapped miners I feel that he drove
the country's economy
forward but not everyone is mourning his
passing police disperse protesters who
gathered in the capital Santiago many
here calling him a
murderer the only Legacy he left behind
was hate and more division than before
pinetta's second presidency from 2018 to
2022 was marked by widespread protests
against equality it prompted accusations
of human rights violations against
demonstrators but he's also remembered
as the man who led the country during
the unprecedented Rescue of 33 miners
trapped for 69 days at the bottom of a
mine which riveted not only Chile but
captured the world's attention a state
funeral will be held on Friday Stephanie
Decker Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz
Z